huge proportions of the maths that you
learn
especially as you go further is to say
this doesn't look like a problem i know
how to solve
it but i'll make it into a problem that
i know how to solve and then if i go
like the machia i'll give you a quick
example just because we're looking at
exponentials right
if i gave you this here's a different
problem for you
okay um
sorry i'm going to change the numbers
just a teeny bit because that one there
is not going to be very easy to solve
that's that that's better okay
if i gave you this um
i would think it'd be fair for you to
say i don't know how to solve that
like what am i supposed to do with this
um there's not
like i'm i'm thinking okay exponentials
like do i
uh am i gonna do like some some calculus
here and that kind of thing
but it's not all i need to do to dress
this
unfamiliar problem all i have to do to
dress it up as a familiar problem
is to do what we call a substitution
right so what i'm going to do is i'm
like those exponentials
look gross so and maybe just ring some
bells right so like if i just swap it
out
then what i can say is e to the power of
2x
is actually the same as e to the x
squared think about your index laws
right the 2 and the x are just going to
multiply together
exactly so therefore it's just u squared
minus u
minus six and you're like i know how to
solve these this is just a quadratic
um can you tell me the pair of numbers
just equivalent
it's just a quadratic can you tell me
the pair of numbers that will add to
negative one
but multiply to negative six i can never
remember this you can do it
or is it multiplication in the beginning
the way i remember it is
um generally this number on the end here
generally it's
fairly it's large in comparison to the
other number so it's multiplication
which is not always the case but it's so
frequently the case that it's a it's a
huge full
rule of thumb so if this is the one i'm
multiplying to
you and this is the one i'm adding to
it adds to negative 1 or they add i
should say and they multiply it to
negative 6. can you think of a pair of
numbers
think think think
[Music]
would it be easier would it be easier if
you just had a six
what numbers what are the factors of six
yeah that does help actually it does
help right
it's two two and negative three two okay
so you saw oh with just six
it's just all positive right it'll be
two and three the fact is it's it's not
just
positive 6. it's got a negative there so
therefore negative 3
positive 2. so let's go ahead and write
that down negative 3
positive 2. like so okay so now i've got
a factorized bit so i can say oh i've
got solutions to this right u is
negative 2 3 or 3. now at this point for
a quadratic i would normally stop
right now you substitute but i'm like
yeah i made it a quadratic it wasn't
really
i'm going to say well that's e dx is
negative 2
or e to the x equals 3. now we're not
out of the woods yet
but we can we can work this out um x is
up there
in the in the index right so i need to
write this in a way that makes it easier
for me to see what's going on
so it's an exponential equation which is
gross what's the opposite
it's a log right so there's a couple
ways to think about this
log base e x yep log
whoops no log base e to negative two
equals x
ah so so you're going to um you're going
straight to a line which is correct
but just so that you i saw you hesitate
you're like which order is it again so
let me help you try and remember right
let's just let's just look at this side
first like one thing at a time okay with
this guy here
it's an equation so as long as you do
the same thing to both sides
it will stay equal right agree okay so
what i'm going to do is oh
sorry i'm going to take logs of both
sides
like so log of negative two
like so okay now the reason why this is
useful is because
um i should have probably actually
written it in long form
log base e because i want you to
remember your log laws see this x here
it can actually come out the front does
that does that ring a bell it's been a
while since you've done this
can you see how so much of what you're
learning now it just
it combines and recaptures all these
things you've learned in the past
but says now i need you to master all at
the same time
um it's like riding a bike it's like
riding a bike right
you've got a balance you've got to have
yeah exactly it's like you've got to
master all these skills
so i'm going to do what i just said i'm
going to bring this
x at the front like so so it becomes
x log base e of 8
and that's just one right now here's the
thing
once i do that i'm like oh x equals this
but
now we run into that problem you were
suggesting earlier you've got log of a
negative number
and yeah you're in trouble
right there's no this is um this is
asking
because remember this ln right it's log
base e
what this is asking over here is hey can
you tell me the number
what times negative e to the power of
some magical number gives you negative
two just tell me what that number is
you're like
never gonna happen no we're gonna uh you
could get really big you get really
small but you'll never get negative
so therefore what happens is there's no
solution or i should say no real
solution from here
like we said you were alluding to it
before if you go into weird varieties of
different kinds of numbers
you can you can do things with this but
for us yeah it's not time for that right
so from this side of things you didn't
get a solution
but for the other side i can do all the
same techniques and
it'll give me something right yeah
exactly in fact i can skip several lines
i can go straight to this line i can say
x equals
natural log of three three and that's
that's totally an answer
right that's that's it that is the
answer
so since you didn't get and it's by the
way it's got it's quite important to
know
you've got no solution here but you got
a solution here so what you would say is
in conclusion
x equals log 3 only
can you see how confusing it is if i
don't say that
i've got two lines of working parallel
to each other one says there's no
solutions
and the other says there is a solution
you're like well which one is it right
so the whole point is you've got to
combine those two together
and um draw out that and you can
well here's the original function up
here
and what i can do is it was a problem
right
i'll we'll graph it in a second right um
what i'm going to do is
i'll just prove to you that it works
okay this is i'm suggesting
that x is log 3. okay so i'm going to go
e
to the 2 log 3. take away
e to the log 3. take away 6.
that's what i got okay e to the log 9.
ah very good so that's e to log 9. take
away e to the log
three take away six but e to the log
nine is just nine nine over three and
then
well you could do that too okay but it's
easy just to say e to log three is three
that's a hard one this is this is zero
like i wanted
you see that okay now you said like what
what an essence look like the answer is
i don't know what it looks like we're
about to find out
well i'm sorry how did you just turn
them into nine minus three uh you're
wondering about this guy here
how'd i do that yeah okay let's let's
let's pedal back for a second okay
so just generally speaking let's switch
colors now generally speaking e to the
power of log x
is x this is actually a result that
doesn't get much attention because
it looks weird okay but i'll prove it to
you that it's true
okay i remember now does this ring a
bell yeah do you want to prove it for
you anyway
okay all right let's suppose i didn't
know what it was equal to
you're like i have no idea idea what
that's equal to i'm just going to say
i'm going to give it a name so i'll call
it um
let's call it m for moe okay so you're
like i want to find out what this
mysterious m
is what i'll do is i will um i'm going
to take logs
of both sides so i'll go log of this
equals log of that okay
now when i look at this i'm like oh i'm
going to do the same thing i did before
i'm like this
log x that's up in the power i can bring
it out the front
like so which is log squared so i've got
oh hold on hold on
i've got log x that whole thing comes
out the front okay i saw what you're
trying to do
but actually the logs are separate the
log x comes out the front and then what
you get left with is log e
right which comes from here doesn't it
become plus then
doesn't that become no it's
multiplication
no it's multiplication because it's a
log x that comes out the front
and a log e gets left behind which i've
highlighted that would have been
ln
so what i've got here on the right hand
side is still log of m
but you told me earlier like you're
looking at this thing you're like that's
just one
so what i've got now is that log x
equals log of this
mystery m right m for mystery as well as
m family right
so therefore x equals m so i could have
said that right up the top here
and just say that's that's x right it
just breaks me
e is you know um now for that for that
reason
you've got e to the log nine so it's
just nine your e to the log three such
as three
and then off you go now just because um
i wasn't going to show you what this
looks like but i'm now morbidly curious
myself
so let's have a look at this guy uh what
do we got here so i predict it's gonna
be
a w okay well um your guess is as good
as mine
um we've got a 2x up in the top there
like a morbidly weird looking
okay so that's um that's an exponential
that doesn't look too crazy right and
then what i'm going to do to that
is i'm going to subtract uh this is
interesting
e x ooh
hello that's interesting and then i
think i had a minus six on the end
though
if you have bad handwriting that does
look like a w
a really bad handwriting w okay now um
when i got here i'm trying to
come up with a good scale for us okay um
what you've noticed
is see that spot right there 1.099
right that's what we're finding we're
finding when does this graph equal zero
and sure enough if i pop in functions
oops daisy i didn't want the square root
i wanted the log
of 3 bam there it is
1.0986122 etc